mmm good afternoon and welcome to this
Friday's app clinic my name is Rotem I'm
i'm joined by ian nicholas and exact
senior executive producer alex lucas on
the engineering panel we have Daniel
Pham our NFL expert and today we're
going to be looking at football apps now
if you're watching us live first thanks
for sticking through the completely
screwed up intro that engineer daniel
has provided us because he's usually
great but not today and second if you
have any questions for us or any
comments you want me you want to make
during the show engineer alex is I'm
sorry producer senior vice executive
producer alex is standing by on the
YouTube live stream so he's actually
watching the comments as they go by he's
checking to make sure that we're not you
know going all fuzzy or muted or you
know distorted or anything but at the
same time he can watch your comments and
pass them along to us if you say
anything interesting so I'm really
excited today that you guys decided to
do football yeah the football season is
in full swing and so I've been away from
Australia for a while so I wanted to
kick off and find out exactly how the
the football teams are doing so I've got
this app here Aussie Rules lashes which
is really good when you said Ozzy rules
live I thought this was going to be a
black sabbath concert interesting yes
nice ah no so this is uh yes so yeah
it's used to the I wish to the phone
there although in there or yourself very
slick nice excellent yeah that's not
really what we had in my this is pretty
good I mean it's got some it's got some
sort of I phony stylings here and we
have kind of the action bar but you but
it's not it's not exactly football it
has something about Australia in it well
yeah Australian football that's you guys
are talking about footy right yeah see
that's the thing any any sport that can
be abbreviated to something that sounds
you put it on a baby when they go to
sleep uh is not a sport it's not working
for you Oh No okay sorry I'm it's an
easy mistake to make right i'm from the
west coast of Australia so football Oh
West cuts that explains the whole thing
it does it does but ok so we're not
talking about about Ozzie rules so
obviously we've I thought this through
so I've got this rugby app which is
great works it's it's not quite as nice
to display we don't have the action bar
here we've kind of got the old school
tabs but similarly we've not really
getting it I the the slippers the Blues
is it yeah yeah Brumbies here breads you
know hurricanes uh pool possibly yeah
i'm yeah this is uniform either no
Daniel you feel in it I have I know you
a real song about yeah I know like a new
car plz rules or rugby well who do you
prefer war or woofer in the in the
Alliance Stadium match you know I'm glad
to know that it's not just in America
that we only sell out our stadium oh no
try again foreign boy all right oh ok so
I've made a common mistake I assume that
when you guys talking football you mean
something like this because obviously
what a lot of people think of as
football you call soccer but I did think
this through so I have I had some other
football hat see I knew you were gonna
try this well I'm what's that in I I
knew you were gonna try and pull in that
whole rest of the world football thing
well we have a line I know exactly why
because you know that our main our
primary audience is in Austria this is
true we have a lot of Austrian viewers
so yep thanks for tuning it's you guys
um so I don't know if we've got the
Austrian league here I should go through
cuz I'm so proud yeah I think that's the
Austrian fly so there we go so we can
see we can we can drill in the actual
app itself again we kind of got this
pseudo action bar with the refresh
button which I know you're not a fan of
back button with you you know why do you
know you know why wouldn't I give up
fine we're not doing your Aussie thing
but I get it okay okay we've got we've
got enough no
us audience here that I probably because
every programmer in the US except for
you and me has been laid off uh fine I
do mix I was excited I was excited
because the NFL starting their season OD
in it so yeah if you know the nipple is
the f of football I didn't realize it as
had a chicken game that you were that
you were proud of that's great it's not
just kicking actually there's all sorts
of interaction between feet and hands
and bowls so let's go ahead and take a
look at a few apps from the from the NFL
from that the American football look at
this we can either be an education
everything I know from American football
is from friday night lights so I just
you should be an education yeah well
they play high school rules there don't
they well they worried now as a rule
Elias easily I would assume so all right
so let's say let's get ready for the NFL
season don't we're gonna crack open an
American beer interesting don't we need
a don't we need like a tailgate maybe a
grill is there a grill around here I've
already spilled beer on the table so I
think we are off to an excellent start
alright alright so what do you want to
start with you guys are the NFL experts
some well let's actually start with um
one of the NFL apps I can have that one
hmm so if we go over the tablet one of
the one of the apps that i thought was
really impressive um is NFL preseason
live no nice now the thing about NFL
preseason live it has really terrible
reviews I and there was one really good
reason for that is it's that on ICS and
up actually I'm honeycombing up the
video playback was really really sketchy
now sadly this is because I previous to
Honeycomb they were actually using their
own playback engine for their HTTP Live
Streaming and post honeycomb they went
ahead and yeah well there we go post my
comb um
they went ahead and used our playback
engine and turns out that ours was a
little less resilient than there's a dad
zhem that some streams that i had a
little bit of okay so i think we're
going to need to switch to the regular
camera here because as soon as we start
playing video it switches over to full
screen mode boy you may want to zoom out
just to touch I think so what they've
done is they had a few a few streams
where the audio part of it was malformed
and it crashed our decoder and then it
was unable to recover so once we got rid
of that problem everything was okay nice
I and I like the app there's a few
problems with it but the basic concept
is really cool so what you're getting
here is we start a we start a game you
can look at any game that's already
played we're I believe you can look at
them live I haven't had the time to
check it out live myself and when you um
now here's what's going to happen and
this is this is the problem that we've
seen in the past so we actually can't
get the video now because the because
that one stream crashed it gosh yeah
yeah you gotta kind of know we have the
crash linear uh yeah yeah so let's go
ahead and just pretend the video is
playing that's basically exhaust yeah as
the men might get up you know we should
have just said that to begin with should
have been like oh yeah we blacked it out
because of the man because we're that
good exile this is well done we can
actually see the video here but i
believe it's not coming across his dad
like right in real time yes exactly good
good say okay so what you can see though
is they've actually got a whole list of
all the plays that happen in a game it's
a little it took awhile to figure it out
but these are the orange circles
basically means are some ball movement
and then you get i think a triangle for
a turnover um you get if it's blue it
means they scored you know so they like
for instance here's the yeah yeah 20
yard field goal there and what's really
cool about it is you can go down here
and see where the the plays are that you
want to look at and then if you click
over here then it'll actually bring that
up
on the video oh yeah it'll take you
right to as always like an index yeah
for every play yeah it works really well
nice the the main problem that I have
with it is first it's a little bit
cryptic like there isn't there's nothing
that tells you what the little markings
mean etc and second if you can see the
difference between my quite normally
sized finger and the touch target it is
Lou on the so she's definitely not hit
following that 48 pixel rhythm which
ripens kind of expecting yeah well just
get really 48 DP 48 DP yeah as well I'm
just clicking anyway do the shortcut or
do you have to specifically hit the
actually clicking anywhere does as long
as it has the little eye rolls wrangle
that that means that there is an index
now I I would probably prefer a
different icon yeah because we've always
thought that I when you have a triangle
pointing one way that means that you're
either going to slide oh and see content
that's that's hidden over on the right
or maybe the triangles going to turn and
you're going to get something to eat it
and there's a there's a pretty tough
damn well accepted user interface
guidelines so that users you're gonna
have an expectation around whereas in
this case all it does is click and and
put the video at a different place it's
not even always the right place to be
perfectly honest but it's always closed
it feels like a pretty obvious icon to
use instead would be in fact a video
camera or something like that sure yeah
absolutely you know or some sort of a
bookmark icon I think would be fine as
well some sort of indicator because you
know clicking here kind of assumed that
it's going to be a drill down are you
gonna get more detail on that particular
play right whereas the video is probably
better but this sort of no clue now the
other thing that I would love to have is
some sort of sorting ability you can
sort for instance on scores but you'll
notice that that removes the bookmarking
functionality absolutely that's a shame
so that's kind of gonna be the highlight
that you in a look absolutely you know
like for me I'm all about the passing
game so I'd really like to just see all
the big passes sure that makes sense and
I found myself literally for this game
just sort of scrolling through and
looking for like a yardage number yeah
Oh 15 yards down maybe I want to see
that well it seems like there's a lot of
information going on in this on the
screen but what really isn't clear is
exactly like you have to kind of read
everything in order
anything I know it reminds me of it
reminds me of trying to read the
scrolling output from like a
role-playing game or something right oh
yeah yeah it actually reminds me of so
I'm a cricket fan I'm going to want to
review cricket apps at some point but
it's the same sort of thing where you
have sort of constant you know six balls
and over it's just constant whatever
happened and in those a life I just want
to cut in return just remind the viewers
that you have the power on this show we
do listen to reader comments or viewer
comments we do abide in general by
viewer votes when we're reviewing apps
so you have the power to stop the
cricket madness Oh indeed to force the
cricket madness if that is in the eighth
one nation in d so anyway so the point
is is that you know a lot of people
follow the cricket just by watching the
live commentary and so they've kind of
optimized that process of having the
most important thing first so the number
of runs scored off each particular ball
is the first thing you see if the person
was out and that's the first thing you
see in it I'd like to see the same thing
here so the the distance past seems like
that would be the most important thing
on a completed play yeah or in fact
scoring seems like it should be
something that should be you know fairly
obvious yeah but you can see it feels
like they they actually haven't taken a
huge amount of care here because if you
look at this it actually even repeats
some information you know this is a time
on the clock and then time on the clock
is the first thing you see here is why
so I think this this feels like they're
just pulling it off their newsfeed of
some kind yeah at the same time although
it could be presented in a slightly
nicer format this is some great
information absolutely it really is just
a presentation thing at this point and
the app itself is obviously hugely
useful to any sports fan it's really
just a case here of trying to you need
to make this text bigger you need to
make the touch targets bigger and then
expand the text because I think all of
you guys watching can see that you'd be
pretty lucky you can read any of this
from the camera and in fact as soon as
you sort of sit back from it you're
checking to make sure your prescription
is still valid right it's small yeah and
on a nexus 7 it's it's even
I can imagine is very very difficult a
pretty big tablet as tablets go these
days so you really want to have that
bigger and in fact there's no there's no
need like what they've kind of optimized
for here is to have as many plays on
screen at a time and that's probably not
what you want to optimize for all right
yeah I think you're right i think it
rather than seeing a huge number of
plays where i have to carefully read
each one I'd rather have the information
presented so that I can scan it so
quickly that flicking this up and down
will actually be useful yes absolutely
you know so if I see and and you can see
they've done a little bit like I can
flick this up and down and when I see
this little bluish green color go by
even if it's moving very fast I can see
that because stands out from the rest of
everything yeah so so bravo on that
count now take that idea and extend it
out to the rest of this particular you I
and I think you've got a real winner and
in fact what I would say is you've
actually got the right idea here so if
you look over here on this side you can
actually see that they've got this
really rich and large touch targets
that's probably about the size you want
and the same way that they've got their
sort of background bleed image that'd be
kind of cool than having this done here
all right so you could have the same UI
element over on this side with a big you
know rather than having this sort of
small logo you have that background
effect bigger text more dramatic you
know view free CLE because even here
we've got light gray on slightly darker
gray if you're supposed to be able to
read it make it stand out put it in bold
make it bright white against black you
know whatever you like but I would say
something like this over on this yeah
unreadable read isn't that looks
fantastic yeah it's just beautiful I'm
really impressed so I think I just want
to say one more thing about this app and
that's about the top of the object yeah
absolutely go ahead none of the place no
no I just I just I was just feeding you
lies be known and I'm running oh I like
this yeah I need a blocker so we've kind
of got this it's not an action bar it's
a title bar and you even it's kind of
all wrong right I mean this is a what
okay I can be home and all of a sudden
being Dan Galpin yeah I gotta watch the
cop yeah so it this this at the top and
even here where you're looking at DIA at
these sort of almost tabs turn them into
actual tab so that I stop having to do
scare quotes and and this title bar
should really be an action bar so things
like setting so if I hit this so yeah I
don't even know where to start so this
should all be in an overflow menu and it
shouldn't be this weird drop-down pop-up
thing it should just be a standard menu
affordance now as far as I know this is
a tablet app an app for tablets only is
that right right okay so you don't
actually have an excuse not to use the
action bar because you don't have to
worry about backwards compatibility you
don't have to worry about how your menu
is going to work on other devices you
just make it an action bar and so this
all of this stuff it's fair enough to
perhaps put this in settings but
settings should kind of always be in the
overflow menu I'm not quite sure what
the ? is going to do oh hello so it's
like on screen tips that's actually not
bad I don't know that I'd make it a
primary action again I probably stick
that into an overflow menu maybe display
this the first time the app came up I
don't know if it dont i will say that in
general if you find if you find that
it's necessary to show something like
this it is probably a good clue tell you
that your little to your complexion on
you're not doing a good UI yeah things
should be as intuitive as possible you
know you shouldn't have to explain to
users how things work you should just be
able to plunk this down in front of
someone who understands NFL and they're
able to start sort of getting you know
involved in the app in fact when we do
sort of internal reviews for apps we
find the ones which we like the best are
the ones where rather than ever i'm
sitting down and sort of nitpicking
which pixels should be a different color
we're all sort of actually using the app
and sort of getting involved NAT I'm
sure it's a similar experience for when
you guys have done games reviews as well
and that's what you want you want it so
the people aren't going so wait how did
you get to that screen what did you do
just there it's just like I'm too busy
getting engaged and and I like there's
your dress how much content
you really need to do some user testing
here sit down with somebody um not I
can't emphasize this enough don't sit
down with some random guy who is
probably carrying a blackberry or iphone
sit down with somebody who's used to
using an Android tablet you know sit
down with somebody's actually your
target market and more an Android
application and watch them use it and if
they start swiping their finger across
things are unsuitable and getting
frustrated that's your first clue that's
a sign in fact I saw a little tip so we
can ask why he assesses fine nice try it
so you can slide between weeks yeah Gary
week so the only thing you don't really
like about it is that I think that it's
not obvious enough where you're at like
feeling it most of the view pagers that
we've put out they have some sort of
indication where you are it's either the
little BOTS like you see how absolutely
home screen awards you know it tabs or
something like yeah see because it gives
you that indication of whether you know
how far along you are and obviously at
this side it's obvious that there isn't
anything before pronoun see there is and
that's interesting so well it's wrapping
around it is particularly so I'm a pre
week one and it seems intuitive that
there isn't anything before the first
pre week but there is you know we've got
the Hall of Fame and then we're back to
pre week for which is again kind of
funny oh yeah your wrap around I don't
know that you want if I wouldn't have
made that choice no you know whatever
but yes it's a coal it is valid is just
not now here it's okay what I'm gonna do
yeah I mean I realize my my android camp
hoody to save your google am I left it
seems like the lab coat should be down
because they're not making any more of
them true enough so the other thing I
point out as well as I mean this is a
pretty fast device and this scrolling is
not the smoothest so there might be
something you can do that o to optimize
that scroll speed in anything which
makes the app feel a little janky really
destroy detract from the user experience
so you know when you are designing
things everything should be as smooth as
it possibly can be yeah and this
a lot of times what we see is people are
either using a regular view and
efficiently or they're using a web view
hmm to do some of this the other thing
that's actually a good tip for many
devices they're not all which also
happens to line up nicely with our
design guidelines is if you put a little
less emphasis on the gradients here
especially if that's something that
you're adding in after the fact in
general most android apps and the you
android UI tries to be simplified and
flat we don't go for the bubbly look
yeah and there are devices in the field
that possibly because of that are not
actually very good at drawing gradients
mm yeah this is true I did an experiment
myself with a compass app and just you
know if you do it flat it'll renders
really quickly as soon as you try and
put like a glass top on top of it
everything slows down but you got to
remember that anytime you're drawing a
gradient or a glassy look or anything
like that you're you're touching the
pixels twice as often yeah and in many
cases device and feel bound and that
literally does make it half as fast let
you go all right so the only other thing
we've got here so we've got these tabs
this should probably be actual tabs
rather than these weird pseudo tabs and
again basically this idea of that the
text being difficult to pass easily
being small and and not of high contrast
is probably something you want to look
out throughout yeah all right shall we
should we move on Jesse have to do so
much let's have a look all right well I
think that the the top-rated apps this
week by viewers were actually the
football app for ya the soccer
absolutely yes the football with a round
ball yeah excellent in fact I think now
this International Rules Football also
uses a round ball it's going to save
soccer as anyone which does but it's not
quite true all right let's have a look
at a foot mob pro which I think was one
of the top
on the top resulting ones try and go
back to the home screen so looking at
this straight away so this is this is a
popular app and I would suggest that one
of the main reasons for that is because
it's very useful you can get all the
soccer scores from basically whichever
league you want to watch including the
the major league soccer oh good let's
see if my favorite team real salt lake
is in there apparently not apparently
not so that's that's one thing to be
concerned or straightaways that I'm not
entirely sure what this icon represents
but clicking it should take you to
something I kind of assumed it would be
rankings which makes sense the very fact
that it didn't appear for the MLS
suggests that we're pulling this down
sucks could be it could be I don't
actually mean that of course American
soccer is the greatest like anything
American compared to most Australian
things as what I'm saying oh nice yeah
austrian of course it let's let's pick
on the australians who are all asleep
right now let's do that it seems
reasonable enough all right uh so yeah I
don't know why that's not showing up but
it's just failing to hold down the
dollar and so you want to have some
indication here that it's loading all
right now I'm not a big fan of loading
dialogues or anything like that but
there should be some indication that hey
I'm trying to pull down daughter and if
it fails saying I tried to but for
whatever reason I can't get the
information yeah now i will set the
iconography of this interface is a
little puzzling to me and you're gonna
have to you know just check me on this
because obviously I you know I don't
actually follow soccer uh you know maybe
this is all totally old hat to you but I
see this this thing here and I think
well maybe looks like a list i don't
know that open up apparently what I did
there then I get touches on it and then
apparently this baby over here that it
to me looked like a what I would call a
soccer ball but I'm just gonna go with
leaden actually the top scorers
interesting signif wouldn't have been
obvious to me that really yeah no
definitely not I would have thought
maybe the opposite like if its top
scorers would have been person
maybe even a person kicking well maybe
even a goal I don't know there's a few
options there but definitely the
iconography needs work the idea of
having the action bar here is reasonable
but again i would go with a more
standard up affordance rather than this
pseudo back button confusing is it an UP
button is it a back button is it
different from the back button down the
bottom it's not quite right yeah this is
a longtime viewers of the show know that
I've never been completely comfortable
the idea that something pointed to point
you to the left is actually taking me up
mmm otherwise because this is an
affordance you see rather rice the bun
exactly an affordance sounds like
something you live in if you're on a
fixed income but really does present I
so but the point is that that that space
is as a honeycomb reserved for something
that will take you to the previous point
in the view hierarchy of the application
yeah as opposed to the previous screen
that you were on before which is what
the system back button is for exactly
and the general iconography for that is
that it should have something akin to
your application icon in general that's
with like a left Chevron exactly and in
which in this case we've kind of you
know bounced before between what looks
like a back button and what looks like a
down button so I guess this is an
attempt today at an overflow menu but on
the wrong side he thinks well we're
choosing league so it's kind of settings
here at this point okay but that's the
only thing right I mean it's not like
choose leagues and a bunch of others
done that's true that's true so either
way I think you really want to redesign
this into something more like an action
bar so you know once you go into the app
you've got some sort of iconography on
the top same at the app is now see of
course like all good android users and
I'm swiping you lost watch me there's a
really good reason for people to swipe
first in android tabs go on top MNC
they've already violated yeah I and of
course that makes one thumb navigation
more difficult which we've solved by
adding the swype action absolutely so
even though that might feel
a little bit like a you know an Ambrose
Beast beers / short story yeah I ruined
that by not even saying her yeah that's
really good yeah could've been um you
are you end up having having to move
your thumb all around you know I want to
get to tomorrow why can't I get to
tomorrow by his wife swapping to
students like the normal thing
absolutely yeah so you really want to
eliminate these and replace them with
something which is more like a viewpager
type set up straight away move move this
into an action bar which sits on the top
right get rid of this whole well have a
look yeah so you get rid of this whole
sort of down Chevron button for choosing
leagues if it's something which you want
users to do then make it an action if
it's something which they should be able
to do but don't want to do very often
than it should probably sit under
settings in the overflow menu but either
way sort of it looks really weird and I
do recognize it as and I a glyph that we
used to use in a version of Android at
some point avail you know when / you're
a playwright yeah it was to drop back in
there like something right the cupcake
Eclair days back when we didn't have any
designers and we were basically just
stealing her about the internet just
making it up as we went along pretty
yeah yeah I get none of that stuff look
good I'm just gonna call that right now
it really didn't and that's the beauty
of the new stuff is that it really does
we've got an incredible design team now
would you've really spent a lot of time
and effort thinking about how to make
stuff look awesome so when you can take
advantage of that we see the same thing
here as we saw in this in the air the
previous app where you've got really
small touch targets and really small
text and again like we're looking at the
league here there's no reason why we
can't scroll more if we'd have to see
this is what I love about American
soccer by the way we've got real salt
lake mm-hmm which I just can't laugh
enough about I thought I can't bring
myself created say that to me though it
has to be real slightly but what about
this CD Chivas USA I mean what what does
that even mean is it I mean it it's
Spencer owned by the the Scotch company
or is there something called achieva of
which this is the flourishes I could be
they have the Chivas we have anybody
producer alex we have any
youtube that knows the answer to this
mystery nobody's commenting if anybody's
windows honking at all or sorry no
nobody's comment nobody's answering your
question okay are they seeing stuff
about us not really no this is anyone
watching right yeah this thing on people
are watching nice hey guys also how do
you like my haircut do you notice I got
a football haircut true story and I've
got a football grin too terrifying yes
uh so yeah I mean I don't know I was
trying to figure out what the story was
between behind CD chivas earlier today
and I couldn't offer the life of me
figure it out um I don't even know
whether where they play I don't know
it's a mystery the good news is that the
san jose earthquakes which is I guess
our local team is leading the Western
leagues awesome yeah right down there in
San Jose absolutely yep so you'll be
used car dealerships in the check
cashing places sweet side going get
weeks paycheck cashing places I san
Jose's second largest business that's
all right what's its top business oh
that's a safe for work I guess Adobe how
to do it yeah all right so yeah well
there you go and see and this is the
problem writer and this is a really good
tip if you find that your users are
exiting the app unexpectedly then your
navigation is broken and that's the sort
of thing we see the most frequently
where people are using multi kube got
multiple tabs here and so you're jumping
around and you're choosing different
things and then you get back to here and
if you've pressed a bunch of buttons
yeah I want to go back to where I was
and you can't quite remember where you
start it's like well I want to go back
to just the list of things and it's like
oh wait no that wasn't it all this
although it's someone telling that I
wasn't disappointed he's actually kind
of thing with with sports absent
generals we just had a talk on Thursday
internally about some sports apps and
one of the things that that I think we
all agreed on is is these are incredibly
challenging because they have to present
a gargantuan amount of information in
sports if you think about just how much
information needs to be presented and
all of the different ways that you can
slice it and dice it it is a serious you
I Challon absolutely but that's a great
reason to really think this through and
to always follow Android UI guidelines
because the more you can make it like
all other Android apps the more you can
make consistent you I decisions that
people are going to expect the more
usable your apps going to be and you
have to hire usability because you've
got so much to present that your app out
of the gate is already confusing
absolutely I mean anything which is so
rich and data runs that risk and so it's
really the navigation is probably your
biggest challenge but otherwise I'm in
the app itself is pretty good you know
you've got your stats you've got your
scores you know all the sort of stuff
really the key here is that this whole
app just kind of needs a navigation
refresh and NAU i refresh something to
bring it up to standard with sort of
year at your ICS type typename adrene
and and slay us and i'm just going to
make one other comment on the units the
the gradients here hmm i don't like that
i think it's unnecessary and the thing
is i'm a big fan of ribbons i think i
think gradients can look really
incredible and and a lot of times
they're much better than a flat screen
but a they are a little bit tired right
now but their swim bet they've been done
that kind of the lens flare of the two
of the tins right but more than that
gradients look good in isolation when
you stack a bunch on top of each other
like this then the eye starts picking up
this pattern and it ends up looking kind
of cheesy it does it really does and if
you're not going to have them sort of
you know flowing between different
colors like some sort of old-school like
jukebox type scenario then yeah it's
it's just going to be distracting
instead
right so in fact if you look at some of
the things that we've done with
gradients that I think we're very
attractive hmmm we've done things like
take a list and then put a continuous
gradient all the way down the screen
behind it hmm that's also fairly
expensive absolutely yeah easy to do and
not all devices can handle it but it
looks fantastic whereas just stacking
these up like this is yeah it's it's a
waste we have a couple questions on the
stream actions awesome awesome athlete
live questions first Gerald Smith asks
overflow mini what does he mean by that
if you could describe what going a
little more detail about what you're
referring to when you say the overflow
menu absolutely so the overflow menu is
the the extra menu options that you see
on the action bar when let's have a look
fire up took it up for the overflow menu
lace drawers go over the place does has
an overflow moaning okay there you go
perfect so this is the overflow menu
here let's try and just get to the
standard action bar if we can so here
we've got the action bar this is your
typical actions and then everything
which is behind that menu button is the
overflow menu so that's where you want
to put things which users need to get to
but it's probably not the most important
thing so settings anything like about
account information you know the sorts
of things they have here a perfect
example of what you want to put any
other flow exactly and it's worth
mentioning that the overflow menu
contents can actually change on business
if they haven't but there are apps where
given a little bit more horizontal space
you'd actually see more action icons
over here on the right and then the
overflow menu would have fewer options
in a gmail friends yeah gmail typically
in general what you want to do is think
of your action bar as having two
essential pieces you know one over on
the left you've got the navigation piece
and that is split into your up
affordance in this case as we talked
about the left Chevron movie icon and
usually some indication of where you're
at in this case it's our search result
NFL and then potentially another
navigational piece like a drop-down yeah
uh and then over on the right you've got
the second major portion of your action
bar which is the action piece and that's
going to be a set of icons if if you
want you can put text here as well
although that's usually not quite as
effective it certainly takes up more
horizontal space now and then the
overflow now you will also see on some
devices on some abs a menu that looks
like the overflow menu down here in the
corner now we call that the menu button
of shame and the reason is the only time
you see that menu button is when you
haven't updated your app for an SDK a
target SDK that's greater than honeycomb
absolutely and the most so now this is a
possible change so there's there's two
versions of this there's the the
unfortunate version where you've got a
nap and you have an updated it yet and
so you haven't figured out how your
pre-existing menu is going to work with
an action bar and so that takes a little
bit of thought so that's not good but
what this is is the real the real button
of shame which is here and it does
absolutely nothing it's all you need to
do is change your target SDK and that
will go away you know the worst thing is
on some devices with with custom ui's
having that button there will actually
do a bunch of layout changes oh wow
they'll actually put them the menu
button on over the top of the system
button it's nice so having that be empty
is extremely unfortunate me now you just
thinking of screen real estate for
absolutely no reason at all nice okay I
was that was there another question yeah
a lot of the drill dislikes that no I
next question is from Ross Larson who
says can we talk about app permissions
here I couldn't install this year's
version of the NFL draft tracker app
because my app because my device didn't
have an onboard GPS oh you know it's we
would love to talk about app and we in
fact we should do a a complete show on
our permission I think we will I think
we'll do a nap an office hours on
permissions right but the problem is
don't have any show called the Friday
rant that's sure the Friday right you
still haven't I gotten permission to
utter pornography you're on for now Ruiz
profanity sonography interesting and
profanity obscenity that will be ready
shared with permission although I'm not
a hundred percent sure the disaster for
committee they're all there also
features come into play well I think
that's this is the this is the issues
that if you request certain permissions
then for legacy reasons that implies a
feature requirement as well on GPS is
one of those if you request either fine
or coarse locate well know if you
request fine location then the system
will imply that well actually you can
probably meant to require GPS as well
yeah so you're absolutely right you know
being unable to install that on a system
that doesn't have a GPS is an indication
that the app has done something that we
consider to be sketchy first they
haven't made it so you can have a
optional permission that are an optional
feature but more importantly they're
requiring fine location which is unusual
and almost always indicates that they
have an ad network that's attempting to
track you at an inappropriate level yeah
this is true i mean it obviously it's
going to depend on the app and you're
gonna have to figure out based on you
know what they offer that makes sense
and I suspect if it's you know if it's
anything which is displaying video they
may be using the fine location to figure
out where you are to make sure that they
have the rights to show you that video
in that location course location we do
that as well right I mean it should
generally be at the very least city you
know accurate to a city level which
should definitely be sufficient for
anything they do is if you if you are
doing that then that's it's totally
insecure because you're just trusting
the client to say where it's out that
could be hijacked so easily so I think
most men go services probably a little
bit clever well the in general they'll
do IP filtering which is easy poof as
well but more costly yeah okay so and
for developers out there wondering how
you get around this you can simply
specify a user's feature and specify a
location as as required false which
effectively makes it optional and then
within your app you'll need to check to
see whether or not there is a GPS or
some form of locations
sensing hardware available before you
make those location update requests and
consider that not just for GPS but for
other things that you may or may not
find for instance back facing camera
that's game Evelyn yeah yeah if you ask
for a camera well I several devices and
the most important one to us being the
nexus 7 do not have rear facing cameras
and the rear facing camera is what you
get if you say you need a camera I think
that's a little confusing on us it can
be but it's one of those legacy type
deals where are you know when we put in
the the users feature and permission for
a camera there was only rear-facing
cameras so uh yeah in general I think
the rule of thumb is don't ask for a
feature or permission unless your app
depends on it that's it that's what your
app is all about if all your app does is
take photos then by all means say that
your camera is required but if your app
has any other functionality for instance
viewing sets of photos or applying its
respects to your photos then don't
require a camera because people might
want to do that with the stuff that
they've uploaded to Google Plus or the
things that they've downloaded from
their camera or whatever just keep in
mind for those users Nexus 7 users
aren't going to be outraged to find that
they can't take photos with your photo
taking app given that they have a device
without a camera so you definitely
figure that they exactly they'll know
what to expect so you want to give them
as much as they can so they can still do
you know the other things okay I'm just
gonna say we've we've covered a grand
total of two apps don't and engineer
Daniel is over there gone like this so I
can engineer channel sexist next year's
the producer of the show but that's not
as engineer because engineer Daniels
gonna be on the next show right so he
just doesn't want to have his time in
the Sun curtailed by by us going over
that is very true Iran to leave Daniel
it the truth is I think we've looked at
what most of the apps in this category
do you know pretty deeply now feature
wise and in terms of the mistakes that
we've seen people make so why don't we
just really quickly do a lightning round
with the FB I think all of the sort of
sports updates news and scores i think
is are all going to be pretty much along
the same lines did you want to have a
spend a couple of minutes looking at any
of
fantasy football apps uh I think we'd
better not I think I just uh you know we
talked we looked at the one app that had
some things we didn't like about it and
I think it'd be fair to look at some of
these other apps because I should be new
things better or worse a you for
instance d FB i-- despite the fact that
it's completely a german i found myself
liking it a lot more it's just got
emotional conventional style here we've
got a normal action bar with a normal
layout navigation on the left swallowed
you know looks like yeah it makes me it
makes me feel like i'm reading a sports
page yes this is a kill and this is
again something we discussed internally
it's like the thing about any sports
news information is that imagery is
really important to that and so we watch
sports for for the imagery it contains
and so you want to have something which
is like reading a magazine lots of
images officer video it's a full bleed
content so that you're sort of you sort
of swiping through looking at stuff and
getting seeing what catches your eye
yeah this is only powerful in fact like
the only thing that i would love to c is
for these pictures here to actually be
larger so now we've we've complained
some about apps that put text over
images when that's inappropriate
especially for social apps for instance
then have images that are user created
you never know exactly what you're going
to get in this case you do and it's
almost always appropriate to bleed this
through just the way they've done here
exactly the way that you've got it here
on the title of it was just all of the
the items in that list done the same way
i think that would look that test now
did you see it just synced and the in
the sink hey John wrote automatically
you to ferry not very nice I don't know
what this is nothing Goods the crash
button it's a the equip exit button
right on what you can see they've done
exactly what we asked in the action bar
perfect which means I know exactly how
to use this application I know that I'm
gonna see actions up here I know if I
want to share it's gonna be there I'm
guessing this is making a text bigger
smaller that's nice sense if I want to
save this for later what am I gonna do
you can hit the style right absolutely
star button waiting it's kind of the
wrong color but that's okay and I
probably won't start I said a little bit
so that it doesn't get the edges one of
those European Starbuck but you know I'm
nitpicking it a point
different over there the other thing I'd
also um no issues you and the and the up
affordance is a little little sketch
yeah it's not quite right the other
thing I'd point out as well as we have
this mixture of of vikon style so you
can see here that we presumably using
the the system built-in icons for
refresh and share but the ones that the
you guys have built themselves are
slightly different colored so I don't
know if this comes across on the video
but these are gray and the custom ones
here or white really hard to get right
it is hard to get right but it's worth
doing and it's also worth doing them all
yourself so rather than depending on the
system to provide some use the system
provided ones I believe they're
available for download from
developer.android.com / design these
days and so this way you don't have to
worry about the system changing any of
them on it on a different implementation
although hopefully that won't happen
newbies Monday orbit yes there's
particularly fair with different
manufacturers putting skins on their
devices you never know if a certain what
icon thicken it provide so by providing
them yourself you had that security okay
and just really quickly I think the last
thing we were going to look at was the
live score thing see loading countries
right there by my American sensibilities
yeah yeah out the window ya see quick
setup should be should be done
automatically so you know again you
don't want to have to go through and do
all of this the first time you just want
to jump straight into whatever you think
is the most obvious now whether that's
choosing countries based on the current
location using coarse location to get an
idea or just picking the countries which
most people use all those sorts of
things are going to provide a better
experience of people can get started
straight away yeah absolutely so of
course I'm gonna I'm going to follow
real salt lake
that's gives me okay so in general this
side this has some good stuff going for
it you know it's obviously sinking or
something but it's showing me something
well yeah it does right away and that's
really important yeah and it's a really
pretty it looks nice again the text is
really really small I think it's as a
common problem from people who are going
we have so much data how do we display
it all at once well you don't have to
display it at once right better to have
fewer things on screen and let people do
a flick scroll or a very last thing that
I want to mention is although this looks
like an action bar hmm it's not it
doesn't act the way an action bar does
it doesn't have an up affordance it
doesn't have actions on the right hmm
it's got navigation here but one of the
navigation things is more which does not
include it's not just navigation in fact
this is really most of most of this
stuff should belong in the overflow menu
exactly so you might want to think about
actually just moving to a standard
Android action bar or if that just
doesn't suit your sensibilities may be
moving to a drawer pattern or something
like that solutely and that is
definitely all the time we have believed
in it will eat slowly have some really
pleased about that thanks very much to
our engineered and fam and our producer
alex blue toss and i think it's about
time sign yeah i think all these so not
so we're going to have engineered daniel
is going to come in front of the camera
and join you i think this weekend yeah
to have a look at some NFL games mm-hmm
as I should be exciting I'm not sure
what we've got scheduled for next week
in terms of the app clinic do we do we
know for certain we actually ever
decided yet but you made a great post on
G+ asking for topics so I think
we should take a look at that and you
know she was based on what people might
see perfect all right so merciful do
plus right it was yeah so we're gonna
we're going to go through that list and
see what what you guys want us to have a
look at and we'll update the moderator
page with the details for that and and
look for your suggestions over the well
what is for us here in the US at least
labor day long weekend excellent so
until then enjoy the weekend and
hopefully stay tuned for the Friday
games review goodbye